[Music]
welcome back to yank speaks everybody
it's your favorite not andrew yang
co-host coming at you every thursday
this is zach browman and carly riley
as a fun reminder
i think this is our second last time
we're gonna do this carly because or a
not so fun reminder
well maybe it's not that fun we have a
lot coming down the bike starting
october 5th guys andrew's books coming
out
and we've got a new studio we've got new
guests we've got yang coming back whole
bunch of fun stuff coming out
what's that he's coming back twice a
week
twice a week oh he's gonna be all day
every day he's gonna be too much here
constantly
just can't get rid of him um but on
today's episode folks got a couple
things as usual we want to cover what
the media is not covering well enough um
either they're not covering it all
they're not covering very well let's put
it that way um so three things i want to
talk about we want to talk about
facebook
apparently being aware of how bad it is
and being caught knowing how terrible it
is for teenagers and what that i feel
like the media is covering that is it
covering that i would think i think it's
covering that but i don't think the
right perspective is caught are covered
um
uh the media is covering these but i
think they're they're not covered the
right way um the second one is uh maybe
less covered is el salvador
is essentially just moving to bitcoin
for its citizens well it's made it legal
tender it's made bitcoin legal tender
yeah el salvador bitcoin coin is
happening and the mayor of san francisco
who has the strictest max mandates in
the country essentially got caught
without one and then doubled down on it
and i want to talk about it so
let's
dive in
facebook
under fire this week anytime is tech in
the news like to get in there um so a
couple things happen wall street journal
give them some credit
dove in uh two scathing reports on
facebook uh one was less cover than the
other one was that
apparently facebook has a
private registry of very important
people celebrities politicians who kind
of exempt from their strict content
posting rules that govern all of us that
didn't get a ton of news that makes
sense to me as a for-profit company
frankly i hope andrew yang was on that
for a little bit maybe get i don't know
whatever that means that's not a point
the bigger one was that facebook's
this was big facebook
own researchers had documented the
psycho psychological dangers of
instagram which facebook owns of course
that put that instagram post a teenager
specifically teenage girls the quotes
were this we instagram make body image
issues worse for one in three teen girls
teens blame instagram for increases in
the rate of anxiety and depression the
reaction was
unprompted and consistent across all
groups and internal studies showed that
among teens reported suicidal thoughts
13 of british users and six percent of
american users trace the desire to kill
themselves to instagram which is sad you
know my first thought when i heard some
of this
was i'm actually surprised it's not more
in terms of like one in three girls say
instagram make their body image issues
worse i would be surprised if it's not
actually higher than that right like
that's what's reported or that's who
will say it but like
it's hard to imagine any woman
especially a teenager right who's
on instagram
seeing all of the
versions of bodies that people want them
to see and they're not feeling more
insecure
let me ask you this um as from a woman's
perspective um because i'm i'm not a
woman um
if it's not instagram
like i feel like
facebook and instagram have just
accelerated what was already a thing
like if it wasn't instagram it was mtv
if it wasn't mtv it was magazines it
wasn't actually yeah fashion shows like
uh like i think part of the distinction
teenage girls and guys but in this case
teenage women are going to
be insecure and they're self-reporting
in some of this this study um
is that
is this is this the scapegoat for
something that a lot of teenage girls go
through with or without instagram or do
you think that's actually accelerating
making it worse
oh no i definitely think it's
accelerating it i think the number the
number of hours people are spending on
instagram is i think a is just more than
the number of hours people were spending
yeah
probably or in magazines the other thing
is in in some cases it's your peers
right so like now you're not just
comparing yourself to kim kardashian or
you know kendall who you can say okay
but they're photoshopped and they're
famous or whatever now you're looking at
the version like your friends versions
of what they want to present themselves
as or people your age right or people
who feel like more like quote unquote
normal
who are also just presenting their most
idealized self in most scenarios right
and or who themselves could be face
tuning or airbrushing because that's the
other piece of this is the is the way
that filters impact this like the
filters people put on instagram and so
i think that takes it to a whole other
dimension is now you're also comparing
yourself to people who are supposed to
be normal but who are also probably uh
doctoring things and it it just it
absolutely makes it worse than just mtv
or
magazines
yeah okay and that makes sense and i
think it's one thing to know that
there's the hot girls in school um and
and not be invited their parties or go
to their parties and seem
you know looking hot every once in a
while it's another thing i see it every
day yeah the pictures and liking it
the like thing
exactly exactly and i think that that
honestly like i think the likes are a
huge part of all of this right like
i can't imagine if i had been a teenager
when
well i guess you know i had facebook and
likes were sort of a part of that but
like it's just a whole new level now
right like if i was 13 and 14 when like
instagram and like culture i i just
think it would be really really hard so
i don't know what the answer is here i
mean i know there were there were uh
proposals put up i think by the
employees when they were fined of
facebook when they were finding this
stuff but i definitely think we should
be protecting kids i guess this in some
ways ties to the conversation you and i
had last week about
china banning video games past three
hours or limiting video games three
hours like we need to have protection
against what kids are seeing now you
know how do you protect them from seeing
their friend looking hot i don't really
know but what are your thoughts well
here's my general thoughts all right
i think face facebook to me is pandora's
box and we have opened that [ __ ] um
this company has found a business as it
has the ability the tech ability to
connect the entire world
and it is incentivized in doing so
by making a profit um it has four
private motivations and therefore it is
incentivized right now um by controversy
by engagement by people talking so
um
i think maybe this is stupid maybe i'm
wrong i just feel like this is bigger
than zuckerberg i feel like zuckerberg
and the facebook executives don't i
don't think any human could possibly
fully understand the beast that they
have created it's taking down
governments it's destroying us from the
inside you know we used to talk about
too big to fail i think this thing's too
big to run like it's so so big it's
larger than almost every country um
and it's making us i mean the studies
are crazy um now facebook did put out a
response which i thought was funny um oh
funny and a couple things one facebook
refuses
to admit
publicly that social media ever causes
harm what they will say is that social
media and studies are inconclusive but
there are no objective peer-reviewed
studies that are showing social media
doing anything
positive for mental health right those
don't exist but they're there what is
what is the advantage to them of not
saying yeah we get this as a mixed bag
because then they feel like they have to
say what they're doing about it well
then they would have to say we're
creating evil or creating something
that's you know their mission is to
connect the world and do positive things
to the world and let's be real we know
that facebook and the internet we like
it like in memory many ways we all use
it it does do a lot of good there's
plenty of outcomes in the internet um
and social media but i do think it's
weird to say with a straight face that
they're there's no it's inconclusive it
just seems so bizarre like any it
doesn't pass the smell test like i
didn't need a study to tell me this was
bad for for women's mental health like
well the other thing that they said carl
was that um and i actually kind of agree
with this they're like
like you're calling they're saying
you're calling us irresponsible
but the real irresponsible thing to do
would actually not do our own research
on this which i do agree with if they
fundamentally didn't care they wouldn't
be running studies now maybe they're
doing these studies to check a box i'm
not sure or they're doing studies to
like
i don't know know what they have to have
like counter messaging for
i
don't want to do anything about it what
or even acknowledge the problem then why
are they doing the studies well that's
my point i do think they do some things
because there are it's a big ass company
but there are some human beings within
that company that try there are plenty
yeah yeah right absolutely um but the
realistic thing that i'm getting at my
point is why should they like
you know we could say i'm not saying
they shouldn't from a moral standpoint
but the only reason you could argue that
facebook employees and leadership should
try
to not ruin people's mental health
is
one their moral obligation like their
own ethics and code which is not
incentivizing that company at all um and
that company is designed to cut the
other way and just make money and not
care um and then the other one is really
just to navigate pr crises and how does
that work all he has to do um and then
maybe the government as a third but um
new regulations but right now all zuck
has to do is navigate each crisis one at
a time duck his head in the attention
economy until our attention span goes
somewhere else that is literally all he
has to do then he gets to go back to
printing cash and ruining our minds have
you seen among the people who
hate zoc and hate facebook and
absolutely think they should be doing
more like what
the call like what the proposed
solutions are because i do think it is a
really hard thing to
combat without completely just killing
your product like your product is
selling aspirationalism like you're
selling the very thing that's causing
the problem
i am not an expert in this neither is
andrew we have had some guests on that
are close to experts or experts in their
own lane we have talked about a lot of
like a lot of
solutions um any the solutions can go
from
helping people profit off their data um
switching from uh
um to like a netflix model like a
subscription model and maybe the
government paying for that as a trend
how does that help with girls
self-esteem issues is what i'm talking
about well i mean then it gives facebook
like trying to change the incentives for
facebook because right now the
algorithms are
right designed for engagement um and
there's ways that if that starts to go
away you can now it doesn't always help
if girls want to go look at other women
to feel insecure or because they want
you know because they're yeah let's be
clear
yeah they can seek it out they're not
trying to meet feelings here but yes
yeah you know what i'm saying
um
but my there are and then there's others
there's plenty of congressmen and women
that have said we should break them up
there's um here's my idea my idea is i
do think we have to regulate it because
we talked about this last episode uh
it's unacceptable we need to do nothing
um i don't know what you can do but my
first thing
is uh my suggestion is facebook free
fridays i can't remember where i got
that from i don't think it was a yang
thing maybe it was facebook free fridays
just try it one day and that's just
facebook it's
it's awesome
but probably all social media um
and
you could get the tech giants in a room
and probably hammer out a way to make it
fair so like make them required to like
what shut down on fridays shut down yeah
oh god i don't know i feel like there's
like literally like the military has
like social media strategies like we
can't like you know what i mean like the
military
tracks social media usage and facebook
can turn off
the button i'm sure
here's something that i want to
highlight that i i actually that is
connected to this conversation and it's
a shout out to jamila jamil who's the
actress from the good place she's a big
activist
uh and she i know has worked and lobbied
so that
i believe it's it's accounts with you
know associated with people under the
age of 18
and specifically women but i it applies
everyone uh
aren't shown ads for weight loss
products
um because that's you know as we talk
about body image that's part of it too
is you have
girls seeing like tummy tea right which
are really basically just like diuretics
that
make you go to the bathroom a lot and
like that's like just really harmful
things and and reinforcing this idea of
like lose weight lose weight lose weight
to a population that's already very
vulnerable to feeling like they need to
be thinner or need to be whatever right
need to be hotter um
so i'm super in support of that that
very much feels to me like you know you
can't advertise cigarettes to kids um so
i know she was she was a huge voice in
that i believe successfully got that put
in place
on instagram where the
weight loss products cannot advertise to
people
so that's awesome um i think you know
depending on on
you know where we are with with all of
that doubling down on some of those
kinds of initiatives definitely would be
positive
i think it's one of the reasons why
andrew doesn't like when we keep talking
about oh this solution be this solution
be great because the reality is in order
for things to get done and either right
now it takes heroes to actually do it it
takes someone like gang to stick his
hand in a freaking running machine and
run for president with
um
everyone laughing at him would take
someone like who you just mentioned
jamil who's um
what's your name jamila sorry jamila
um to like do a herculean effort to get
congress to actually take some like
that's what it takes right now and
that's because government's not working
and that's a lot of reasons why he's
doing what he does and why we love him
so
facebook free fridays would love your
thoughts hit me up
[Music]
[Applause]
all right guys i've been traveling a
good amount this summer getting my
breather in and one of the things i
actually missed the most is my mattress
like i've been sleeping on matches that
are fine like decent hotels but is not
my helix mattress and helix sleep has
the best mattress on the market i love
this freaking thing
um i've had guests come in our home and
casually sit on our bed and they're like
wow this thing is awesome because it is
so here's how it works helix sleep has a
quiz that you take online for two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress for you so everybody's
unique helix knows that so i have
different mattress models to choose from
from soft to medium to firm great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot great
for spinal alignment prevent morning
aches and pains all these different
things for different size of people or
types of people or how you sleep so i
took the quiz i got the biggest mattress
you could possibly find it cools me down
and it's like medium soft is where i'm
at so
if you're looking for a mattress
or if you just want to upgrade a little
bit
take the quiz
find the mattress that works for you and
it gets shipped to your door for free
you don't have to go to the mattress
store ever again and you don't need to
take my word for it it's literally been
the best
this was named the number one best
mattress in 2020 by gq and wired it's
been recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors so this thing
is awesome so go to helixsleep.com
yang take their two minute quiz they'll
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life it's true they also have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out free
for 100 nights so don't miss this we're
giving you up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows pillows are
clutch for our listeners that's
helixsleep.com yang get 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
[Music]
[Applause]
carl is in your wheelhouse but i saw
this headline and he asked me about it i
saw that el salvador had
i think the number was 1.6 million
people
have a bitcoin wallet in a country of
six million people um
so
uh yeah i can
speak to this so please tell me what's
happening what they're doing and why we
should care yeah i'm i'm super super
super excited about this
as you might imagine if you know
anything about me which is that i love
crypto um
so
essentially
back in june the el salvador in el
salvadorian president announced that
bitcoin he was he was going to put a
motion in place or a law in place
basically um for bitcoin to become legal
tender in elsi in el salvador um and
that just recently went into effect so
it is officially legal tender you can go
to a mcdonald's in el salvador and you
can buy a hamburger with bitcoin you use
a qr code like people are doing this
every day and you actually are required
like businesses are required to accept
bitcoin now there are some exceptions
like there are certain businesses that
haven't gotten set up with it yet
etcetera they're not being penalized but
it is official legal tender so
bitcoin i'll give you the brief history
here right for folks who don't know um
el salvador
uh is a very poor country you have a
tremendous number of people who live on
like less than 4 000 usd a year
about 25 of their gdp
is
remittance payments i think they're
called but basically people expats
living outside of el salvador sending
money back into the country that's 25
of
their gbp you have people who have left
el salvador left a country in south
america and now are somewhere else
earning a living and sending money back
to their home country and to their
family that's one scenario the second
scenario is you have people who are
still in that country but work for a
company
that's in a different country so for
example
i am working with somebody now who's
based in argentina who was working for a
us-based company and was getting paid in
crypto
because
the alternative was to get paid in usd
and then to transition those to pesos
where he was
the central bank would take a huge cut
of his money
so it
taking it in crypto was a way to
maximize his salary
so that's common without throughout
south america that was you know a huge
part of gdp was coming from those kinds
of funds in el salvador specifically but
i think there's just take a step back
even further the very brief history of
call it money in el salvador very very
brief is they had a currency called the
cologne if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
but it fell subject and fell prey to
what a lot of these currencies do which
was high rates of inflation after a
civil war in like the late 70s early 80s
in 2001 el salvador adopted uh us
dollars as a legal tender and that has
been like the primary currency in el
salvador now for the last 20 years
um but you have
the us printing us dollars
uh
like crazy and then controlling the
circulation in and out of el salvador
which was causing a lot of problems for
the country they were very at the whims
of the united states and our central
banking system
um
70 of our of of folks in el salvador uh
are unbanked right so
the president of el salvador has now
come out and talked about this quite a
bit because you have
all sorts of folks mad that bitcoin is
being made legal tender mostly folks who
have a vested interest in the dollar
continuing to be a a prominent currency
in el salvador and the president was
like look you all had 20 years
to help get more of our people into the
like traditional financial system and
you did not do it
you don't get to complain now that we're
finding another another route um the
thing that i'm sort of most excited
about this is
simultaneous to it there the government
is funding educational programs crypto
education for individuals and
institutions around the country
um
that i think is awesome it's like
financial literacy in general right um
and so that's super exciting the other
thing this is wild that they say they're
doing is that they are going to be
mining bitcoin
using
heat power from their volcanoes
so they're using their volcanoes they're
claiming to
mine bitcoin and then the president has
said that bitcoin will be used to invest
in infrastructure projects around the
country so like this guy bucheller
seems incredibly for you know whether
this works or not i mean he's bold and i
think it's really really interesting
what he's doing he's also incentivizing
investment in bitcoin in the country
saying you'll get permanent resident
status if you invest more than three
bitcoin in el salvador so you can and
that includes like real estate you can
buy a house in el salvador um and okay
we're buying el salvador for some
bitcoin
this is look i think when
el salvador isn't it has more financial
literacy education on a public level
than the united states of america we
have a bit of a problem um
but
this is what you've been talking about
crypto carly which
cryptocarly this is what you can talk
about crypto carly uh
in that
there's a world where
a country like el salvador who probably
missed the boat on
financial market boom of the past
100 years or so um
is now able to get access to the next
one because of uh the way technology is
making this more accessible am i right
well for seizing the opportunity right i
think that's
that is what i'm so excited about and
amazing you know i've been doing these
like info sessions on zooms and things
uh because i do want to get more people
into this space because i think we're at
this really pivotal moment and we will
be for at least a little while longer
right where you have an opportunity to
like
change the fates of people in really
prominent ways because of this
technology and because of the wealth
it's going to create the wealth will be
lost as well make no mistake about it
but i think um
i think it's incredible i i love that
he's
trying something here i mean you know i
hope it works out for them and um
i i think it's really exciting i i love
that he's embracing it so many countries
are are
you know trying to overregulate it and
they don't even understand it so uh well
held up del salvador ethas down but i'm
um i'm
hey hey now let's do your research and
then if you determine you like i'm not
an investment professional this is not
official investment recommendation
i think you
um
okay
the last thing i want to talk about is
something
that this triggered me i think it i'd
say it triggered me um and i think
um the press has been covering in a
certain way
but i wanted to um
give
maybe a lesson from someone who grew up
in a republican leaning household
why stuff like this pisses off
republicans so much so
the mayor of san francisco
london breed
um
was caught maskless at a club at a
concert a nightclub
and
um
now i want to be very clear i care less
if people wear a mask in a nightclub
especially your vaccine like do you okay
this is not a personal thing on that
sense um but this is this made in a lot
of news both on the left and the right
um but of course on the right because
san francisco
has the strictest or one of the
strictest i'm thinking i believe it is
the strictest um mask mandates in the
country and they require you to wear a
mask indoors at all time they have since
august um and they did a lot before then
too but as of august for the delta
variant um so she was caught in this
video
dancing having fun having a blast
listening to tony tony tony who hadn't
performed in 20 years which was very
cool concert glad she got to go look
sick um
however
and then when asked about it
this is our leader who made the mask
band-aids who's enforcing them
wait can i this is the part that makes
me laugh i love this part do you know
what she she called pete called it
she she's like
the fun police that's [ __ ] you you're
the fun police
ah
so by you you mean london bernie it's
ridiculous her quotes are it's sad that
this is a story
because of how awesome this concert was
they had a rare performance okay no i'm
gonna take it she said this this isn't
zach i'm paraphrasing but she said this
um and she said i was there i was eating
i was drinking everyone was vaccinated
i'm not gonna sit put my mask on sip and
put a mask on eat put a mask on these
are dragon balls she she was saying that
she had just put her drink down when she
stood up to start dancing but she was
still drinking
i mean just put her mask on which is not
true it's a long video she's not she's
not wearing masks no one's wearing a
free mask which is fine um but this is
my point i want to i want to say
something right now i really want to say
something right now i have to just
scream but calm down
for those of you listening that are
democrats um
and
or you have friends that are democrats
and they say words like this they say
phrases like this because i hear them i
hear them a lot and the phrase sounds
like this i just cannot understand how
someone could vote possibly vote for
donald trump i just don't understand how
someone with a heart who's not an
[ __ ] could possibly vote for the
republican party
and believe me i'm a democrat i've asked
these questions myself too and i hear
them often
i'm here to tell you that this moment
right now what this mayor has done is
exactly why
that's why
because i know it sounds stupid but to a
large percentage of this country
that type of hypocrisy is like
unforgivable it's the jonathan height
talking about authority and purity like
the values that republicans really value
or people who say what they mean and
mean what they say and they're not going
to talk out both sides of their mind so
if you're the mayor and you're the
leader and you say you have to wear a
mask inside
and then not only do not do it but then
when called upon it you pretend it's not
a big deal
okay
i okay so i think here's here's the
thing i want to say is again if you're
somebody the hypocrisy is people like
i'm i'm really a true democrat like
through and through so like i
i really
kind of understand where she is coming
from um
but i will where is she coming from okay
oh no please tell me i will get to that
i will get to that but i was gonna say
if you are a democrat right like it's
not about whether or not you think it's
reasonable or not for somebody to
vote on an election based on this kind
of hypocrisy right like the left is
gonna be like are you effing kidding me
like abortion is such a bigger deal than
this hypocrisy so what i'm trying to get
at is it's not about what you think like
you just have to accept that somebody
else thinks differently right like i
think that's what we break down is like
great to you this is not a big deal as
compared with abortion and i would
certainly agree with that well no i'm
actually you took it there i'm not
taking it there a republican wouldn't
say that i mean maybe if they had an
abortion conversation what they would
say is that how could i trust you and
your views on abortion when i came and
trust you to wear the mask that that you
are requiring your own citizens to wear
like i can't trust you for anything
you're a liar you're a hypocrite and you
should not be in charge that's what
republicans say so but but so now let's
actually get down to it right so because
the mask rule
is not that you have to wear a mask
while you eat right like so when you're
sitting at a table
inside i can read it to you if you'd
like
let's i mean what are you saying not
while you eat she's not eating in the
movie or in the video
what she is saying right like i i think
and i was getting i was saying this to
you i think earlier right like
first of all of course i agree it's
totally distasteful it's like
embarrassing it is totally why people
[ __ ] on democrats because it just feels
like this elite mentality which is like
you the masses can't handle like
to like you know be responsible enough
to go mask this but i'm special and like
i understand this is a vaccinated room
so it's fine for me like it reeks of all
that elitism that is just so like gross
to
i think a lot of people but republicans
really chafe against it but i do think
there's this element of like all right
you're having a covet outbreak you have
to set you're like you're trying to set
a rule
kind of as as far as you can
understanding that people are going to
break it right but understanding that
like
yep obviously when people eat
they're not going to be wearing a mask
like that like
in she's not eating
okay and her point is
and she's saying she adjusted but no
that video has a mask on
it's a concert i don't care they're not
wearing a mask i care that you said no
one can wear masks and no one's doing it
it's indefensible
and it's bad leadership and we should be
upset about bad leadership in this
country because it's driving us in the
ground i'm so sick and tired of people
like oh it's okay like this leader's
worse like bad leadership bad leadership
that is a definition of bad leadership
we deserve better as a country
i was asking i'm pissed off you should
fight for it excuse me okay i was asking
you this earlier um which is what is the
punishment if you don't wear a mask
inside
so we're trying to look this up it's
county by county so it's probably county
officials like who control like the
business permits that focus but you
residents can submit complaints to the
department's website
if they're not wearing a mask and the
theoretical situation is that they can
lose their business license if they
don't have mass now it depends on the
state i know in new york i mean no i'm
asking about california i'm not in san
francisco where this mayor lives i'm
talking about like it's enforced on a
vague basis so here's my point if you're
gonna have a like if you're gonna be
vague about enforcing it then don't have
the rule and if that's her points like
these rules are stupid we should be
going out having fun and not wearing
masks and getting vaccinated then don't
make the rule but you're in charge you
made the rule you've been supportive of
the rule you tell
has she spoken on the rule before
yes what's her job
it's her rule
she said i can send you the website you
have to wear a mask you must now wear a
mask inside at all like you must wear
ass indoors in public places even if
you're vaccinated
done period the end sf.gov
it's not black it's not gray it's black
and white if you want to make don't do
the rule
um i understand
if she was like forced to do this rule
and she's like think she's stupid but
there has been no evidence that she's
done this or else it wouldn't be a hot
take
no it's a it's a it's a really bad look
it's really bad and this is the point
i'm like well they're like well and and
democrats will say this well trump's
more of an [ __ ] you think this is
worse than like you know putting kids in
cages or things like that that's not
what i'm saying i'm just saying that if
you're on one side of the aisle and
maybe lean right or whatever it is and
you see the left doing this
like
you'd rather have the [ __ ] that's
honest with you than the the liar that
but that's not all i don't know what
you're getting the funny thing is like
it's like there's nobody on the right
honestly
i know but he's not right so like
like he's like
you know like you say you say he's not
being an educated person who's done
their own research and looked at
independent sources or lots of news
sources the type of people you're
talking about don't trust
the cnns they don't trust msnbc so when
people call them a liar they don't
believe it okay but but what i'm trying
to get at right is like
it's
as easy to see that trump is lying right
as it is to see that
she's been a hypocrite right because
like it's literally he will say one
thing on a presidential debate stage and
like a month later say a different thing
like you you only you can just be
watching what he says and it's clear
like he said mexico was gonna play for
the wall like and then like you know
like it's so so
[ __ ] easy to see that he is lying and
speaking out of both sides of his mouth
i think that's what democrats find
frustrating is like there seems to be
this like like i think republicans get
really mad at democratic hypocrisy and
somehow like don't seem to mind
conservative hypocrisy and it's like huh
this like like your your level of anger
on this feels like and you i can attest
are very much democrat like your level
of anger on this feels like so much
higher than it is on like a bunch of
conservative lies and i get it because
there's like the elitist thing where it
feels like you you guys tell us
like trump's saying mexico is going to
pay for the wall i'm like not being able
to i probably have a better example
there are better examples
i think trump's come back right i think
i think trump is more lie than he says
like he's
justices after having god knows how many
abortions and abusing and being a
chauvinist right because of women his
entire life like there's your epoxy
right i'm not saying
like this is my problem like this and
this is where we're at now where it's um
we have this moral
relative morality that we have where
that look what london has done is
morally wrong in my opinion i think a
lot of people would say hypocrisy and
why that is wrong but then we say well
trump has done other things wrong
and he's worse it's like
okay maybe
um or maybe in this case yes yes right
like yes
but that doesn't make the first one
less bad it's all dog [ __ ] um yeah i
mean
i i just like i i totally get it right
of course this was a bad move of course
i don't think her her response to it was
professional right
i i just very much see the scenario
where it's like she's got some like
health administrator in her ear being
like hey delta variants cases are going
up whatever whatever's going on right
and they're like you know that you know
she's got 10 000 things on her you know
given legislative plate and or i don't
know how the what the legislation looks
like in their shops you know what i mean
and you've got the the health finisher
being like all right we're going to put
in this rule that like hey like people
throw masks indoors we're just like
reinstating the mask thing you know like
whatever she's like yep great whatever
she goes out she's having a night she's
vaccinated she's eating and drinking
which is when you're obviously not
wearing a mask she stands up for a
minute she's nursing her drink she's at
a concert right like i i
totally get it's a bad look i totally
get it shouldn't have happened
i also totally get how that happens and
like
you know no i guess it was not a it
wasn't a one-off moment it was like the
mask was nearby she was not wearing
mascara entire concert and then she
doubled down pretending the rules are
stupid the ones that she enforced and if
you're living in a town in this country
that watched the whole thing every small
business in that town shut down because
they weren't allowed to have people in
there during covid yeah
bend over backwards at mass and then
watching leaders around the country like
say the rules but they don't apply to
them yeah watch the polls like democrats
think they're gonna hold that hold fort
in 2022 they're going to get rocked and
it's because of stuff like this because
democrats be like oh trump is bad things
are worse and other people down the
country get fired the [ __ ] up and that's
what happens and anybody who's like who
lives in those states knows what i'm
talking about
i get it too like i i think i i do find
it a disproportionate reaction compared
to other things and i think that's
what's frustrating for democrats is like
wow you get so fired up about this and
yet like
literally that
again but like i think that in general
like that sort of like where i come down
on it and so it just feels like i'm
my self-righteous feeling is like i'm
somehow able to manage to like keep a
sense of proportionality around my
outrage about it that doesn't mean i
don't agree that it's ridiculous i i
mean the the business shutdowns really
made me very angry um i think that yeah
businesses to close um and and mess with
people's livelihoods like that i i feel
very strongly about that as well much
more strongly than i do about like this
mayor not wearing a mask one night and
look and being a hypocrite though i find
that very disappointing you know what is
the other piece of this puzzle i know
we're being a dead horse but there's
another piece of this like these masks
these rules these announcements and then
the news cycles that come they create
fear they make people want to stay home
yet when our leaders are going out and
partying like it's no big deal like
there's the signal that's the leadership
that drives me nuts where you have folks
that are staying home they're not
spending local stores they're not going
to the bar they're not going to the
museums whatever it is and that's
hurting small businesses whole and local
economy
wow
to our leader eh no big deal like uh fun
police like it's yeah the fun police
client does really feel like are you
kidding me it's just like like if you
can't see why that doesn't rile up a
whole bunch of people like you just i do
i do see it not you i'm you know
collecting the royal anyway we've gotten
zach triggered for a day he's in a
relatively good mood because the bills
are one in one josh allen looking a
little rocky it's been a uh like we're
getting the offensive gear but buffalo
bill's defense is out of control guys we
blank the miami dolphins
baby suck it 35 to nothing on the road
oh my god awesome poor john is gonna
have to do so much volume editing on
this because your levels have been
possible but i'll tell you what
oh he's putting on the bill's hat oh
uh john thank you for editing and make
me sound good guys we love you we'll see
you next thursday
last episode together let us know your
comments
let us know your comments if you
disagree hit me in the youtube section
hit me on twitter in the beginning of
all this all this i was reading the
comments really religiously i've been
bad about it i apologize i do like
interacting with you guys and comments
um i just got busy with work things and
then also like just yeah whatever
feedback but it was really just like i
was like oh okay there's only so much
feedback you want to take on at any
given period we've now ended this
podcast no one's still listening but we
have yeah we've had it tuned in go bills
bye buddy bye
[Music]
you